[Musik]
die wichtigsten deutschen aktive teil
drei anwesend anwesend
abwesend abwesend
guten morgen
sind heute alle anwesend
sind heute
anwesend
es füllt rudi junior
es fehlt gut junior
dann haben wir heute einen abwesenden
schüler
dann haben
wie heute in dem fall einen abwesenden
schüler
anwesend
abwesend
interessant interessant
weil ich langweilig
erzähl wie war dein erstes blind date
wie war dein erstes blind date
es war eine interessante erfahrung
[Musik]
leider war er ein langweiliger typ
es war eine interessante erfahrung
das nächste mal triffst du sicher einen
interessanten mann
nächste mal trifft sicher einen
interessant
langweilig
teil 1 und 2 schon gesehen
v
fleißig fleißig
er ist ein fauler mensch
er ist ein sehr feiner mensch
er hingegen ist ein fleißiger mensch
er ist ein sehr fleißiger mensch
foul
fleißig
hell
dunkel dunkel
liebe kinder was ist wichtig abends im
straßenverkehr
was ist wichtig
im straßenverkehr
wenn es dunkel ist sollte man helle
kleidung tragen
genau wenn es dunkel ist sollte man
helle kleidung tragen
mit heller kleidung sieht man euch
besser in der dunklen nacht
stimmt dann muss ich über meine hellen
haare eine dunkle mütze anziehen
dann muss ich über meine hellen haare
eine dunkle mütze anziehen
naja
[Musik]
oh nein habe ich laut gelacht
hell
dunkel
das nass
trocken trocken
zum glück habe ich den schirm dabei so
habe ich trockene haare wenn ich bei der
arbeit ankommen
ich habe trockene haare
mein schirm ist kaputt ich habe ganz
nasse haare
[Musik]
trocken
müde
ausgeruht ausgeruht
ich bin müde von der arbeit
heute gehe ich früh ins bett
ich gehe heute früh ins bett
dann bin ich morgen ausgeruht
dann
ausgeruht
müde
^ ^
tief
t
das ist ein hoher berg
ja das ist der höchste berg der schweiz
das ist ein hoch
berg
ja das ist der höchste berg der schweiz
weißt du wie der höchste berg der
schweiz heisst
was machst du da
ich habe ein loch
das ist aber ein tiefes loch
es ist ein sehr tiefes loch
hoch
ängstlich ängstlich
mut
mutig
der hase ist ein ängstliches tier
die mutprobe
der hase ist ängstlich
die hase ist ängstlich
was für ein angsthase
der tiger ist mutig der tiger ist mutig
ich bin das mutigste tier der welt ich
bin das mutigste tier der welt
scheiße
hey hey hey hey übermütig
ängstlich
mutig
frei frei
besetzt besetzt
es hat keine freien plätze mehr
alle sitzplätze sind besetzt
es hat keine freien plätze mehr alle
sitzplätze sind besetzt
entschuldigung sie ist dieser platz
besetzt
entschuldigen sie ist dieser platz
nein dieser platz ist frei
frei
besitzt
gera
gerade
krumm krumm
das ist eine gerade linie
das ist ein
schade linie
zeichnet eine gerade linie
[Musik]
nein
das ist doch eine krumme linie
das ist eine krumme linie
so sieht eine gerade linie aus
nein
[Musik]
gerade
krumm
riesig riesig
wind sich winzig
er
ein riesiger spieler
er ist ein riesiger spieler
er hin
ist ein winziger spieler
er hingegen ist ein winziger spieler
riesig
winzig
flach flach
style style
das ist aber eine flache landschaft
achtung hinter
er hat es einen steilen abhang
achtung hinter dir hat es einen steilen
abhang
loch
stein
hart
weich
das ist aber ein hartes brot ist es von
vorgestern
du hast eine zu weiche matratze
du hast eine zu
die matratze
mein rücken
erst heute
hat
weich
lebendig lebendig
[Musik]
tot tot ist immer etwas los in so ist
immer etwas los
[Musik]
so ist eine lebendige stadt
sie ist schon sehr alt
sie ist eine tote frau
bello ist ein toter hund
[Musik]
lebendig
tot
höflich höflich
frisch frech
das schaf ist ein höfliches tier
das schaf ist eine höfliche ist ihr
guten tag der her
ich würde gerne einen cappuccino
bestellen bitte wenn es ihnen nichts
ausmacht
ist dieser stuhl noch frei
neu besetzt
der affe ist frech
der auf
ist frech ein freches tier
höflich
frech
klug klug
dum dum
er war ein kluger mann
ja er war einer der klügsten menschen
hier ist wirklich an
politiker
hier ist wirklich ein dummer politiker
klug
dumm
normal normal
außergewöhnlich außergewöhnlich
er ist ein ganz
mahler fußballspieler
er ist ein ganz normaler fußballspieler
er war ein außergewöhnlicher spieler
[Applaus]
normal
außergewöhnlich
[Musik]
www.hhl.de deutschen punkt ch
danke fürs schauen bitten leike das
video und abonniere unseren kanal
[Applaus]
klicke hier für teil 1
hast du teil 2 schon gesehen